there is way more to Tekken 7 story mode
that you might expect it's obviously
taking a lot of cues from other fighting
game and features long stretches of
narrative as well as a few surprises he
is just a small edited collection of
what we saw there are some minor
spoilers ahead but nothing you don't
already know if you're into tech and law
to keep tabs on Tekken 7 be sure to
subscribe to games behind I believe that
love was all anyone needed for some
years now I've been investigating a
certain father and son and I managed to
get a hold of the first letter of the
boy wrote to his father it said father
one day I will tear you to pieces
come on
mónica Latinos to go
no pain in the neck
hmm Tokiko loss in Oh demagogy Steve
Isuzu monetary No
[Applause]
Koreans who fight
you put on Duke
-
[ __ ] you
we're not
G Corp were at war with the Mishima
Zaibatsu and it appeared that they had
the public on their side people believe
that the die Basu had started the war so
it was only natural that they saw G Qin
as their saviors however my reporter
friend came into my hotel and barely
able to contain his excitement presented
me with the picture
[Music]
it revealed G corpse true colors which
conflicted with their public image the
picture shed light on the incident that
had occurred only a few months earlier
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know I feel God works on the ground
now
budding them we throw we love instantly
[Music]
frustration had become a part of my
daily life eventually I ran into a guy
in a restaurant as I burned would been
almost ungodly fighting spirit and he
looked at me and thought you could see
the darkest depths of my soul so you're
the one who's been looking into the
Mishima Zaibatsu Affairs said before
making his way to the exits the way he
stared at me from the door let me know
that he wanted me to follow
[Music]
hypnotised i walked slowly towards him
as we left the restaurant he formally
introduced himself
his name was Lee Chawla accident task at
home Oh querida Kleist or condo jojomo
Breda - guitar oh what a sewer said
cuckoo hmm kkeok system and her mother
says Oh deny you that you see so cuckoo
knee-high just curious he ran up to us
[Music]
you look